Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
it seems to be that in the Korean
Peninsula zigs runs of war are
constantly rumbling and it's certainly
true that this area is not known for its
peacefulness but the kind of tension
that the area has been recently feeling
have not existed for some time the
United States the country which already
had 30,000 soldiers deployed in the area
has also deployed several aircraft
carriers heavy bombers and even an
advanced anti-missile system in South
Korea it is so advanced that China has
even considered it a threat to their own
security China tells us to remove
anti-missile thaa ad system from South
Korea amid spying fears North Korea on
the other hand keeps carrying out a new
tests with ballistic missile sounds
progressing with its nuclear program it
seems that North Korea doesn't really
care about all the international
legislation about non-proliferation and
nuclear testing Japan and South Korea
are feeling understandably tense they
want to know what to do what decisions
to make step by step in order to stop
the growing threat that is kim
jeong-hoon
but not North Korea's most recent
missile launch is absolutely intolerable
yayan victim attempts we already told
you in a previous video here a visual
politic about how Japan is seriously
considering putting an end to the
pacifist nature of their constitution
and it seems that right now even they
Jin has had enough of Pyongyang trying
to reportedly sent 150,000 troops not to
his border if this story were a movie
you'd probably leave the cinema thinking
that the writer had taken too much
creative Liberty dynamics violence
savage axis
spectacular thrill Godzilla king of the
monsters but what is really happening in
this region what can we actually expect
well that's what we're going to talk
about in this visual politics video
above before we get into all of that
let's get some perspective where are we
and how did we get to this situation
North Korea is some sort of nightmare in
the past it's a country still living in
the Cold War a country with one of the
most totalitarian governments in the
world and along with all of that it's
also one of the poorest countries on the
planet according to the United Nations
two out of five North Koreans suffer
from undernourishment busts Kim jong-un
the guy who controls the country with an
iron fist doesn't seem to give a damn
about any of that so it is estimated
that Pyongyang started to develop its
nuclear program around the 1980s and
since then there have been a few key
situations which has sped up this
progress the first was the fall of the
Soviet Union in 1991 then game george w
bush's incorporation of north korea into
these so-called axis of evil in 2002 and
then the wrister coming to power of kim
jeong-hoon in 2011 we could say that
every time the regime felt threatened
they decided to accelerate the process
barson we're going to discuss that later
in the video the issue is today
it is estimated that North Korea holds
from 10 to 20 nuclear weapons and
according to the RAND Corporation if it
doesn't stop producing them the North
Korean program could accumulate around a
hundred nuclear bombs by the year 2020
let's do wait for just a second because
this isn't the end of the story but now
the technology used in this country is
well it's pretty basic it's based on old
designs from the Soviet Union
so the bombs they have developed up
until now they don't work brilliantly
VFL physical cycle are you guys exactly
and that is why Pyongyang is now
obsessed with two things on the one hand
attempting to militarize the bomb so
they can be placed in missiles on the
other hands developing ballistic
missiles capable of attacking targets
that are thousands of miles away ante
the last tests they've conducted
indicate that they are probably making
some important advances
many analysts including the intelligence
services of South Korea and the United
States have considered that North Korea
is already capable of weaponizing short
and mid-range missiles with nuclear
warheads which could allow them to reach
South Korea and Japan and so that's not
all it seems clear that if the program
doesn't stop in a few years North Korea
will be capable of attacking the United
States of America with ballistic
missiles this would be a significant
strategic leap for North Korea and that
dear friends is a redline which is
causing the Pentagon many many headaches
so now you might be wondering well that
in the u.s. done anything to stop this
country and well the truth is that they
have tried almost everything the US
strategy per year the United States and
South Korea have trying to persuade
Pyongyang to abandon their plan of
developing nuclear weapons and well they
didn't have any problem taking out the
checkbook in order to do this in the
early 90s 1994 to be specific Bill
Clinton signed the agreement framework
by which North Korea committed to cancel
its military plans in exchange for
generous fuel help from the United
States as well as assistance to build
two nuclear reactors for civilian use
with this agreement North Korea obtains
the energy they needed to develop the
economy as for South Korea besides
giving a huge amount of humanitarian aid
they also committed to boost and finance
North Korea's economic development
programs it all seemed to be going well
for a while however it all those pieces
in 2002 when george w bush found out
that Pyongyang had been fooling them in
secret North Korea had kept developing
its nuclear programs for military
purposes after more negotiations they
reached a new agreement and Bush's
administration restarted their aid
program and lifted sanctions
thus a year later Pyongyang reneged on
the deal
despite all of this Barack Obama decided
to try yet again
in February 2012 they reach a new
agreement North Korea canceled the
nuclear program and the United States
restarted once again the economic game
this time Pyongyang broke the agreement
only six weeks later all right so now
you're beginning to get the picture so
now you might be wondering well why are
North Korea so insistent on having
nuclear weapons at all what are each
looking for the regime of Kim jong-un is
pretty set on developing more advanced
nuclear weapons and the international
community is going to have to get used
to the idea that this is not something
they are going to abandon but that still
leaves us with the question of why well
first of all because they think nuclear
weapons are essential for their survival
young-young knows that we have nuclear
weapons around no foreign power
especially the United States would dare
to intervene in the country when the
United States invaded Iraq North Korean
leaders they were paying attention but
then the first mistake Saddam Hussein
made was not having nuclear weapons and
other WMDs they thought the same thing
when Gaddafi's regime self Libya had
voluntarily cancelled its program for
development of WMDs a few years earlier
so the North Korean leadership thinks
sounds honestly they're probably right
the nuclear weapons are the best
guarantee to staying in power further
the sales of nuclear weapons technology
is one of the main sources of foreign
currency coming into the country
currency that needed so the elite can
maintain their standards of living since
the fall of the Soviet Union North Korea
has become one of the main exporters of
missile equipment technology and
components
u.s. ceases North Korean ship taking
missiles to Yemen also indications are
that North Korea has sold you clear
technology to Iran and advised Syria in
the construction of a nuclear reactor
that Israel bombarded in 2007 Israeli
strikes targeted Syrian nuclear reactor
the Telegraph it is precisely this risk
of proliferation which is why the United
States is trying so hard to stop North
Korea the other reasons is of course do
you try to prevent this country from
being capable of threatening the United
States with a nuclear attack and so well
now we come to China and what China
thinks of all of this China one thing is
certain if it weren't for trying to
support North Korea would have never
developed its nuclear program and it
isn't just the technological part that
we're talking about here all these
support to avoid international penalties
it's also the money China accounts for
more than 90 percent of North Korea's
total trade deal enk in other words
without the support of Beijing this
country would have collapsed a long time
ago however there are some signs which
tell us China well they're a bit tired
of so much provocation then they're not
happy about those nuclear missiles
either it could be said that for Beijing
young yang is now a burden that China
has to deal with as it attempts to gain
influence and leadership in
international politics China takes the
driver's seat on free trade some
analysts have even suggested the Beijing
might be losing control over the
government of Pyongyang which is now
self absorbed by their new nuclear
capability importantly for the first
time in November of 2006 China agreed to
completely stick with the international
sanctions being leveled against North
Korea besides in the last few months
China is forbidden North Korean : ports
and gas exports and well the
international community is holding its
breath that is a significant punishment
for Kim jong-un regime and well there's
more international relations between
these two countries is not at its best
points in fact since Kim jong-un came to
power
no top-level bilateral meetings have
taken place and there are less and less
official visits between the countries so
the question is is Beijing really
changing its relationship with Pyongyang
a road to solution well it is still too
soon tonight but don't be fooled for the
time being China is not going to let
North Korea fall which is still an ally
for them in the region oddly it's not
until they have serious reasons to do so
and well that is a key point to
understand if we want to find a solution
to this crisis China needs to be
persuaded to try and make Pyongyang put
an end to this cancel their nuclear
program and carry out real reforms but
that won't happen under the current set
up that is why many experts think it is
time for the United States to withdraw
from Korea and consider dismantling the
anti-missile system and perhaps consider
some economic compensation as well it is
also important that China understands
that the current situation might need
South Korea in Japan to pursue an arms
race as well as the option of developing
their own nuclear weapons so now we've
told you our opinion here at visual
politics and what we'd love to know what
you think click here if you want to
leave your opinion in a quick survey so
what do you think trump administration
should do do you think North Korea
should put an end to its nuclear plans
should they even possibly be threatened
with war well I really hope you enjoyed
that video if you did please do hit that
subscribe button below the video and
stay tuned for new videos every Monday
and Thursday and do not forget to check
out reconsider media podcast they
actually provided the voice for this
video that isn't mine and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]